Okay. So we talked about some of the differences;
now let's talk about what happens if you don't obey those rules.
I remember, about--this is probably 6 or 7 years ago now,
when we first starting Reddit--
there was a program online called Basecamp,
and it's made by a company called 37 Signals--
and it's used for organizing To-Do Lists and stuff.
And so the page kind of looked like this.
You had like these To-Do items
and next to each of these To-Do items
was a little link that said: Delete.
And this was just a link--and if you recall,
normal links, with the anchor tag that you would see in Click On--
those make GET requests.
To make a POST request you need a form,
and these were just links.
And so if you were logged in, you could create these To-Do items;
and if you wanted to delete it, you could just click on Delete.
Well, there was another program out at the time, called
"Google Web Accelerator".
And what that was, was it was a browser plugin
that would sit in your browser,
and while you were browsing--
you know--let's say this is the browser you're looking at--
let's add a picture here.
While you were browsing, a bunch of text--
you know--there might be some links throughout the document--
the Google Web Accelerator would make those requests, behind the scene,
so that when you clicked the links, the pages were ready to go.
The problem is, the Google Web Accelerator was hitting these links.
So users would go to their Basecamp page,
look at their To-Do lists,
and find that their items were deleting on their own,
and that's kind of a big problem.
And that's what happens when you use GET requests to alter the Server state.
Those guys, at the time, just assumed that since we were logged in
no bots would ever hit the page; it would only be used as clicking.
But if your browser's behaving funny
or if you've got a plugin running that's clicking on all the links for you,
you'd better be certain that those links don't actually change the Server.
So what you should design instead is
instead of making links that alter the Server,
you can make little forms--and the form
can just have a little button in it that says: Delete
or it can have a special link that causes it to submit the form--
but it should be making a POST request.